time for your own everybody
Durell if she wants to attract young
voters Hillary Clinton needs a campaign
Logan looks less like hospital parking
and speaking of logos the designers of
the logo for Sarah Palin's pack should
talk to the guys who draw goofy they can
explain that when you see stars it
doesn't really mean you're looking to
the future it means you just walk into a
stop sign knurl if you make your living
stalking and killing innocent animals as
professional game hunter Ian Gibson did
and you're leading a safari to kill
elephants as he in Gibson was and during
that Safari an elephant tramples you to
death good
and by the way we know the elephant is
the nobler of the tube because when the
hunter wins it's the greatest moment of
his life and when the elephant wins its
ooh what did I step in new rule you
could buy a $75 toaster that burns a
picture of your face into the bread but
if you just want women who stay over -
never come back face up
what kind of Navy loaner says hey look
at that bread you're eating it's really
me
knurled the woman who got a tattoo of
her favorite band the lost prophet and
then found out the lead singer is a
child molester has to tell the woman
with the Cosby tattoo that it could be
worse by the way the worst thing about
getting a Cosby tattoo on your thigh
what happens when your leg falls asleep
new rule once you're dead you have to
shut up about politics
North Carolina's Larry up right yes
Larry up right with such a staunch
Republican that in his obituary it said
the family respectfully ask that you do
not vote for Hillary Clinton and then to
honor Larry they held a moment of Fox
News on mute you know what Larry if you
can think it's funny to campaign against
Hillary Clinton in your obituary then I
could think it's funny that you're dead
and your name is up right
you